okay hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to layers of
fear now someone told me that there are
only four items available to find I want
to turn the volume down a little bit or
else I'm gonna be scared at every single
creaking crack in this house so that's -
oh god can I get a little thank you
that's much better
adapting my let's play on the fly cuz
I'm such a pro so anyway I don't know if
I've been missing a lot of items or
something like that because I've been
trying to be pretty meticulous about
this but that does not mean that I'm
gonna be good
I mean I've very low expectations
yes rum is suspicious some don't seem
right about this one hello Oh
symbolism Oh creators blocks so symbolic
I'm not gonna turn around to screw you
oh oh okay I'm in a box
I'm in a box of emotions I can't process
anything oh I don't think there's
symbolism anymore I don't think
oh oh oh what the hell are you doing to
me this is a bunch of baloney stop
messing with my brain oh oh I thought
that was a head like an indentation in
there that's locked up hello why is
there suddenly power we are relying on
candle power before okay oh [ __ ] you
Thanks I'm just too strong I kicked it
right off its hinges cuz I'm so stressed
what are you gonna do this time oh thank
you okay
what do we got come on who's here
whoa-oh-aah secret haunting mimics knock
knock knock only clothes left behind not
gonna let them in I wouldn't want to let
them either he seems to be made of rats
it's like the spell from the GRANDMONT
some cinderella godmother not grandma
it's gone horribly wrong
it's literally a carriage made out of
rats they're all crawling all over each
other
Cinderella's like maybe I'll pass on
this one
restless memories what was that what I
say I didn't see nothing hey you want
messmate oh god I don't want to mess oh
oh oh oh oh oh is that blood or paint
well I guess I'm painting with blood
nowadays so I guess it's the same thing
a king good flapping horror be quiet
constantly flapping eating other rats is
that the flapping is that a flappy flew
okay okay okay Ulric recollections I get
it you got bad memories I got a bad
memory too
hello okay can't open you
all right Oh bang oh well that made it
all righty tighty okay I seem to have
some strange powers in this house of
mine us creative types you know never
satisfied with the way the world is was
gonna change it all right here seems to
be a lot of my uh late wife's things is
my wife dead
I'm assuming that's the case cuz
otherwise oh I don't know it seems to be
where I started this venture that did me
no good
hello okay oh oh I didn't know I could
do that
apparently I can zoom in who knew hello
anybody gonna spook me here
oh the shadows on the wall sure are good
hi oh I just have to combine shadows and
spooks am I ready for this am I ready
for this where am I going up good oh
sorry
hello lu lu yeah there we go take me on
an adventure I'm ready I'm ready I'm
ready I'm ready
hello
hi oh this is my stop I thought that was
gonna be a secret thingy abandoned hope
while you can
is that a message you're sending to
yourself or is that just what was that
let's see hey sorry I haven't written in
a while I've been swarmed with work I
gotta tell you your last letter was
troubling to say the least I just can't
believe she would set fire to your old
paintings why would she do that the lady
in black especially that was your
tribute to her wasn't it I don't know
what to tell you except to get her some
professional help pronto
you could probably talk to someone as
well with all that's happened I'm sure
it would do you some good
I probably don't need to tell you that
the buyer was sorely disappointed with
the news the new pieces just aren't
selling as well as the classics anyway
I'll keep looking
you just hang in there and focus on your
work I know you still have it in you I
believe in you your friend and agent
Thomas Caldwell I don't is that I don't
believe in my work so I'm trying to say
probably Oh God another suspicious room
what are you gonna do this oh nothing
okay hey there we go hello well that
looks good okay Oh Oh God
I thought that was like aa silent
floaters they clog the drains fur in the
water no baths for me
okay disappearing baby dolls exactly
what this horror house needed yeah
exactly what the recipe called for I'm
just gonna skedaddle
hello another such measures room great
cool all right [ __ ] they're going here
oh oh this looks like a hallway of fun I
can't wait for whatever happens to
happen is gonna happen to know oh hey oh
no oh god no oh no no I don't I was
there light switch it yes oh good
comforting lights I prize should have
gone down there in the dark maybe it
would have been a bit more spoopy let's
get Adil skedaddle skedaddle skedaddle
okay
oh oh that's normal
normal I hear a rumble I don't like that
I don't I don't like any of this why is
any of this a thing
why sees happening oh oh oh there's a
rumbly oh there's a rumbly hello hi
patient thirsty dangling dread furry
leeches afraid to look up I'm not a bird
whoa whoa
never mind I'm perfectly afraid to look
up in fact I don't think I'll ever look
up again up there I go lying
so I was a pointer coming down here oh
here we go
never mind
okay I'm controlling time and fate Oh
oh sorry it's just how shocked by what I
was seeing whoa okay can I go now can I
go home now okay that's did I do that
why did that happen
what the hell was that
okay all right then that's still little
weird
Oh God star [ __ ] what oh it broke
gravity done did bogey to remove the
flesh from the bone at first I was lost
as to how but then I sawed it off with a
handsaw boiled it then put the bone in a
mortar I had to get one obviously this
was not something I done before finally
I mix the dust of some white painting it
made for a lovely under lovely under one
lovely underbite
okay I'm gonna go home now I'm gonna
leave I'm gonna leave before anything
else starts floating before I break any
of the other laws of nature I just put
on my big boy pants and climb up these
stairs
don't mind me a hobbling cuz if that
prosthetic leg is for me don't forget to
turn out the lights
I made of power oh yes okay good good
good good good good good look at my
collection it's getting so much better I
probably have missed some things but I'm
not going for completionist not at all
okay Baba - oh you're painting Oh God
your paintings are getting uh oh so
delightful
I see an astronaut okay and the big bad
wolf in the corner there all right then
well good for me I found another piece
so there should be only one more so
maybe only one more episode of this so
thank you everybody so much for watching
I'm loving this game is thoroughly scary
and as always I will see you in the next
video my innermost thoughts was always
just like one day and I really want cake
robot I got it I got you now see you a
robot I am an alien you are a label